I think it is harder to succeed
when you're disabled.
The odds are stacked against you.
It's harder to get into school,
a local school.
It's harder to go to university,
it's harder to get a job.
So really success is far further
away when you're starting out.
However, when you have a disability
you learn certain things,
like resilience and communication
just because it's how you get by
in day to day life.
And if you're able to harness
those in the right direction
and the right way
then I think that enables you
to be successful.
My first tip is...
I can remember watching Michael Palin
on the TV and thinking,
"Wow, I'd love to just travel
the world like him."
When I was at university,
I decided I would go for a trip
on the other side of the world.
I can remember being at Sydney Bridge
and looking over the harbour
and having goosebumps on my arms
that I was there, I'd done it.
And it was such an amazing
feeling of achievement.
I've not been able
to stop travelling ever since.
I'm definitely
not suggesting that everyone
should do the kind of
adventures I've done
but I think it's very important
for people
to push their own comfort zone
because it just gives
you so much confidence
and a feeling that you can
achieve anything
and you can put that back
into your day to day life as well.
So my next tip is...
...a day.
Creativity is like a muscle
and you have to train it.
Every morning I write
my 10 ideas on my phone.
I write down the numbers one to 10,
I pick the topic.
That could be about business
or it could be about how to improve
my health and wellbeing
or it could just be about
how to have some fun tomorrow.
The point of the exercise
is just to come up with ideas
and there is no pressure
or expectation
to actually use any of them.
The first five normally
come really quickly
but as you're starting to get
near the end it gets really hard
and that's a bit like
going to the gym,
you know that you're stretching
the muscle and improving it.
...is my next tip.
Good communication is key
to all relationships in life,
personal and professional.
So with my disability sometimes
it's difficult doing handshakes
and there's been some
quite awkward moments
where people think
I'm leaving them hanging
and it's just a bit uncomfortable.
But I've learned to say,
quite directly,
please can you shake
my left hand
because that just enables me
not to have to take my other hand
off the joystick.
So I would say overall,
you don't ever have to be rude
or nasty to people
but you should
always speak your truth.
My final tip is to...
Having a good sense of humour
is a powerful tool
and it breaks down lots of barriers.
Particularly in my life,
there are definitely times
where people see the wheelchair
before they see me
and I could get angry by that
or I could try to be
very educating and serious.
So I find that humour is a good way
of putting them at ease
and opening up a more normal
and relaxed dialogue.
When I look back on the achievements
it's quite surreal.
It sometimes has felt,
the last couple of years,
that my life's been like a movie.
So I think there's a bit of...
it's still sinking in
to some degree as well.